Hình hình hình ũn đường xin đến tham qua thì có chung trình dương không ạ
Có chứ bạn ơi
Bảo tăng hà nụ ý hiện tại là có chung trình giáo dụng đặc biệt cho chương thậm
Phong phần là kiểu xếp hà ní quốc, hay giảm học xinh lủ và tương nhạm
Họ bột nâu chứ mà họ học của chức tiếp tại là tạm thì không gì đâu bạn luôn
Thầy về là học xin nha tứ vậy người học thuộc lòng mới thì không chứ ở trong người xa thì
Thầy cô đưa các bạn đến đây, trải nọc chức tiếp vào chủd đe
Đây có giống thiên trên gần, có bạn đồng tương tà và chẳng nhất là không có bài kiểm tra sâu đó
Nhưng mà chắc các bạn đã bảo chế thì người yêu thương kí yếu và chung đầu, rất là ngàn, rất kinh thức nông, rất là dễ kip thu
Dạ, học xinh được làm việc này, hay xin xin thương không
Sau, xe mà xe mà nào, làm nhiều
Thông chỉ xe mà mà đôi
Vì là thuy với chúng chính xin ấy có thể là bao gồm
3 quan theo dưới này, vụ xóc thứ thành này sẽ như công nghệ này
Và tông tham sống ở đây là nhiều tượng, thành phẩm loa ngìn năm, và là dịm
Dùa đầu tiên mà bất kì đoại học xin nào
Thôi bị quên, con em môi tội đến đây thì có thể xin thúc bị khóc
Thúc bị ăn chơi, rất thúc bị đec
Thúc bị ăn, bởi vì là ở đây, chúng em là thích cái chứng trị vụ khóc cho tương lưỡ tuổi
Điều học, học có sử, chúng học của thông
Môi là tội sẽ đều có thử tiếp tận khác nhau
Không phải, một cơ dịch cả đoại mà là chứng trị lũ
Chào tình lực tội
Và, một xương thủ rộ hồ gơ mà cắn khác bị đạm bảo là một chăm mần ra mỏ xin thị học
Nào vào đây, quên thích, mệt nửa tất, mình mấy khi được nhìn
Dùa, chức tiếp đến ngoài đâu
Mời là vấn đề bộ xương của với phy uo
Nhưều tội như thế
Để là thông, đặt chứng trị, cho chương học
Cần làm khi nào
Lên kênh phy đảo tạm để được phương vấn lịch chính phù lợp trị nhé
Chúng tôi sẽ cảm thấy là học xin ra về nhớ ít nhất một câu sợ lịch sử mà
Cả đứa, nhưng quên
Trả n luôn, nó chung là một choo nó con, nó học lịch sửa
Học về những cái văn khóa thì không gì của họ hơn là đến bảo cả hà nước
Đấy, hay cô không phải sản đoán cho vừa đến đâu
Phải nghiệm bán hành chính thức tương không?
Ở, sửa hành nhau mà cho mình cũng sẽ mính tưởng lọc xin
Nhật, ngày xưa mình cũng cũng ăn như mình khó khóc được
Có nơi này để mà học thì mình không lê không ra
Bây giờ có bảo cả hà nước này thì
Hãy cô phụ hình nào nhá, muốn được xin đến thì hay có mềm bóc
Ngày, tưởng là tạm nhá, không là có mềm gì kênh